je travaille seul je respecte tout elle
séjourne qui bon le préfet parfaitement
au courant de notre action je pense que
ça devrait changer si ça ne change pas
tout ça sans nous irons plus loin une
mère dans sa commune ça se fait
forcément interpellé aujourd'hui cette
esthéticienne obligé de fermer à cause
du coc vide est soulagé de pouvoir
parler à son élu c'est la première
personne qui j'ai pu voir et plus et
puis je fais sollicité et je pense que
oui ma mère te faire quelque chose je
pense que l'amérique peut faire quelque
chose pour notre notre région à
montbéliard
marie-noëlle biguinet flore a voté lundi
une motion de soutien aux commerçants
mais elle ne compte pas s'arrêter là
autant lors du premier confinement il
pouvait y avoir une forme d'acceptation
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus possible s'il
n'y a pas une évolution rapide des
conditions d'ouverture des magasins
j'envisage bien sûr de prendre un arrêté
d'autorisation d'ouverture des commerces
sachant qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
légal mais je pense que nous serons très
très nombreux à faire ça elle fait face
aussi aux autres élus de l'association
des maires du doubs indépendamment des
appartenances politiques de chacun
ensemble les maires nous faisons
remonter ces difficultés du terrain pour
être écouté bien sûr par le gouvernement
pour que les choses évoluent les élus ne
demande pas l'arrêt du confinement mais
plus de justice pour les petits
commerçants
ce n'est pas normal c'est une équité
totale de laisser vendre des produits
dits non essentiels par d'autres donc il
faut déjà qu'ils une cohérence de la
part du gouvernement
en limitant bien entendu avant des
produits par les plateformes de
e-commerce sans nouvelles dispositions
gouvernementales les mers prendront des
mesures dès le début de la semaine
prochaine